Hey everyone. Welcome to our first chapter. We're going to take a look at an introduction
to microbiology and we're going to do it in two parts. In part one, we're going to start
with just the basics of what is microbiology. We're going to look at the scope and why it's
important and then even what types of microbes we're studying here. That'll be what we're
going to start off with. So there are always different definitions for the same word as
I'm sure you're well aware, but our textbook defines microbiology as the study of living
things too small to be seen without magnification. Now biology is the study of life. So microbiology
micro means small and so we're just really looking at small life. Now the truth is we
get into things going on inside of these living organisms such as their cells and the cell
structure. So we're not looking at just the organisms, but also how they work and things
of that nature. These things, quote unquote, we often refer to them as microbes or microorganisms.
These are things like bacteria and viruses or some of the more common types. One of the
things I like to point out a couple things really, but number one is that we tend to not
think about these and that's because we just don't ever see them obviously. But it's important
to recognize that these really make up the vast majority of species on earth. Most life
is fairly microscopic. We are as humans really amongst a small percentage of organisms that
would be considered giants. We just don't really think about it that way. But on a percentage
basis, most living things are too small to be seen with the naked eye. Now you can look
at that both from a number of species standpoint, the percentage of species. You could also
look at it, which would even be an even greater majority would just be the number of species,
the quantity, the number of bacteria on earth, would probably outnumber people by thousands,
if not probably more like millions to one, maybe even more, maybe even more like billions
to one, probably be more accurate. So we are things of our size, I should say, are fairly
in a fairly small percentage that is. So microbiology is looking at all of these things that we
wouldn't normally see every day. It's one of the reasons why it's important because we
just don't think about it and yet they have an impact on us, not some of the things we'll
get into. Now the other thing I want to address besides the fact that we are giants and we
don't only think about all these life forms, the other thing I like to address is that
when we do think about them, we tend to think about them in a negative context. And I'm
generalizing here, but I think for the most part, we tend to only worry about things when
they affect us, especially when they affect us in a negative way. And for that reason,
I think that we often only pay attention to microbes when they cause disease and when
they're causing harm. And for that reason, we often refer to them as things like germs
and viruses or a type of microbial, we tend to use that term in a negative way. So the
idea is that while that's true, one of the questions here is why is this term inappropriate
or why is it, I should say, why is it often inappropriate? And the reason is because most
microbes are actually either beneficial or at the very least neutral, meaning they don't
cause any harm. So they're actually either good for us in one way or another. It's not
always a direct benefit, but they're either somehow beneficial to the earth or to people
as a whole, or at the very least, they're just neutral and they don't really have any
positive or negative effect, at least that we're aware of. So that's kind of microbiology
in a nutshell. Study of small things, we're the giants, and we have to just recognize
that most of these small things we just don't ever really become aware of. And a class like
this is what, where I should say we get aware of those things, we bring those types of things
to the front of our minds and to the front of our consciousness. And most of them are
actually not that bad. Most of them are actually pretty good. Now we will focus on pathogens
because while many are good, we have to focus on the bad ones so that we are aware of them.
Now in the next part here, just real quick, the scope of microbiology is very broad.
I don't want to get into this in too much detail here because I could talk about this
all day. But it's important just to realize, as I mentioned, microbiology is the study
of small life. And there's so much happening at this microscopic level that as a consequence
of that, the field has been divided into many different sectors. So everything from a medical
context, even to how diseases are spread as a whole. So you think these are the same thing.
Chemical microbiology, public health, epidemiology, by the way, is kind of the study of how diseases
and things spread. And really these are two separate fields directly related to each other.
But studying them in a clinical setting versus how they spread outside of those clinical
settings is kind of the difference here. Immunology, how our immune system responds. Industrial
microbiology and agricultural microbiology are really putting microbes into a commercial
context for the most part, and using them to make products or enhance products. And some
quick examples there would be things like vaccines. You could use them for vitamin production.
Even things like antibiotic production are just a couple of examples of how these are
used. Agricultural microbiology is studying how they affect crops in crop production and
or how they can be used to enhance crop production. In fact, microbes can actually be used to
enhance crop production. And then environmental microbiology is really looking specifically
at how microbes have an impact on the environment, which is somewhat self-explanatory there.
So we're looking at it from the human standpoint, commercial standpoint, and then environmental
standpoint. So with this class, we try and look at every one of these to a certain extent.
But the truth is we'll focus on medical. We'll talk about public health and epidemiology.
We'll definitely spend a lot of time on immunology. And we'll spend less time on the industrial
agricultural and environmental simply because these first three topics take up a lot of
our time, plus not everything that we talk about here is listed. So that's a general overview
of the scope. Now, this is somewhat opinionated. So take it for what it is. It's my kind of
opinion being very biased. But at least to me, why I think microbiology is important is
it starts with an understanding that microbes are ubiquitous. Now, this may not be a term
you're familiar with. So microbes are ubiquitous. What does ubiquitous mean? Ubiquitous means
something is found everywhere. It's a very simple definition. So I'll say one more time.
Ubiquitous means found everywhere. Now, once again, you'll find different definitions,
different sources, but that's more or less the gist of it. Sometimes you'll hear it stated
is found everywhere at the same time or found everywhere simultaneously, meaning that it
doesn't just move from place to place. It means they're literally everywhere all at once.
Most things are not ubiquitous. Even things like oxygen is not really ubiquitous. There's
lots of places on earth where oxygen doesn't exist. So it's not a term you hear very often
because it doesn't really apply, especially literally in most cases. So why is this significant
then? Well, because they are everywhere. And everywhere we go, we are impacted by microbes,
whether we realize it or not. Now, it's not always a significant impact. But microbes
tend to have some kind of effect everywhere they're found. And that means that they haven't
impacted everywhere they go. So for this reason, at least in my own personal opinion, microbiology
is very important now. Many of you are going to go into the medical field. And really what's
expected of you is just to be aware of what you don't see. As I mentioned, we're giants.
We don't see these little microbes, but they definitely have an impact on us. So really
the goal of this class is not to make you an expert in microbiology by any means, but
to simply bring forward in your mind what these are. So you have a better idea of how
they work and hopefully how to better protect yourself from them. So in the sex part, we
want to look at what are the major types of microbes study. And I broke this down into
really the six major types here. Now, we'll actually study a few other things that aren't
specifically listed here. But for the most part, you can look at them as really a list
of about seven basic types of microbes. So bacteria, archaea, and sometimes we hear that
pronounces the archaea, but I always pronounce it archaea. The protozoa, the algae, the fungi,
the helmets, and then the viruses. So each one of these is very different from the next.
And these are very broad categories. So there's lots of variation within each one of these
categories, but these are kind of the broadest categories of at least the most common types
of microbes.